Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus die Frage wo ich dich
erreiche verkleide ich mir heute aber
wie geht's dir heute die Frage weil
richtig was los nach unserer letzten
Folge es ist erstaunlich was wir
auslösen ja ja ja mein Mann unterhält
sich ja quasi im öffentlichen privaten
Rahmen und das ist schon irre dass man
immer irgendwelche Bedeutung dem
beigemessen wird ja also welche
Bedeutung dir da an dem Punkt doch bei
gemessen wird wir haben ja über Indien
in erster Linie gesprochen gab es
übrigens viele Resonanz und auch noch
viele über dieses Land nachgedacht ist
faszinierend was da gerade passiert und
hab so im Geiste beschlossen ich muss
dringend wieder mehr verreisen würde ich
demnächst auch tun aber dann kam die
Außenpolitik und dann kam Anna-Lena
bärbock und dann fiel ein paar Sätze und
die hatten es offenbar in sich
unter anderem der Satz sie hätte nicht
mal Praktikum bekommen unter normalen
Umständen genau ja ich glaube über
dieses irgendeiner normalen Umständen
haben sich viele gefragt was ich damit
sagen wollte ich wollte sagen aufgrund
der fachlichen Qualifikation ja nun ist
es ja so dass man sagen muss das könnte
man jetzt so Entlastung sagen es gibt
natürlich viele Minister die nicht
hochgradigfachlich qualifiziert sind
also wenn man die Ursula von der Leyen
vier Ministerien leitet die nichts
miteinander zu tun haben dann kann man
nicht fachlich qualifiziert auf jedem
Gebiet gewesen sein also man muss sich
da ohnehin einarbeiten die Frage ist nur
ob bei einem Amt wie beim auswärtigend
ist nicht gut wäre grundsätzlich
jemanden zu haben mit größere
diplomatische Erfahrung jetzt könnte man
sagen die hatte Guido Westerwelle auch
nicht Heiko Maas vielleicht auch nicht
aber in diesem Punkt denke ich gerne
Anfang Walter Steinmeier zurück der das
hatte und den ich einen ausgezeichneten
Außenminister fand und ich finde es ein
bisschen schade dass diese diplomatische
nicht nur Kenntnis ne sondern auch
sozusagen diese Fertigkeit das
diplomatische sprechen was man als
Minister braucht ist das offensichtlich
keine wichtige Qualifikation mehr ist
und das finde ich schade nochmal zu
dieser Kritik regiert wie hast du das
wahrgenommen so die die markanten Sätze
waren ja der mit dem Praktikum dann viel
ein anderer Satz wo ich dachte okay so
interessantes Bild hätte man aber als
verletzend möglicherweise empfinden
können ja das einzige was grünen ihr ist
ist das was sie sozusagen hinter ihren
Ohren hat aber die Farbe hinter den
Ohren der wurde gar nicht so oft zitiert
ja aber das war eigentlich für mich der
harte Satz ich dachte also das mit dem
grünen meine ich insofern dass man als
Außenministerin eigentlich kaum grüne
Politik machen kann also auf jeden Fall
keine Umweltpolitik was ja eigentlich
noch der ist der Markenkern das Grün
Seins ist und ich deswegen von Anfang an
das auch für falsch gehalten hatte dass
die Grünen das Außenministerium für sich
beansprucht haben das habe ich auch
mehrfach gesagt ja dafür hätte man auch
zwei andere Ministerien bekommen können
mit denen man deutlich mehr von der
eigenen Programmatik umsetzen kann
und deswegen habe ich damals schon mal
Joschka Fischer nicht verstanden dass
die Grünen das Außenministerium haben
wollten und ich habe es auch jetzt nicht
verstanden weil das natürlich das wofür
die Grünen stehend stehen nicht wirklich
umsetzen kann
ich ich habe schon ein Gefühl dafür
warum man das genommen hat Außenminister
sind in der regelungsfassbar beliebt und
wenn du noch mehr werden willst in der
deutschen Politik dann dann wirst du am
besten aus Ministern tust du keinem so
richtig weh und empfiehlst dich quasi
automatisch für öffentliche Ämter das
kommt keiner wenn du die Rivalität
zwischen Werbung und Robert Habeck dir
anguckst ich meine wie kannst du denn in
diesem Rennen die Nase vorn haben Robert
habe hat einen Ministerium ist glaube
ich das größte ministeriumsalmässig
da ist legst du dich den ganzen Tag
legst du dich mit halb Deutschland an so
als Außenministerin kannst du da kannst
du glänzen auf dem internationalen
Parkett produzierst interessante Bilder
und ich finde das beherrscht sie auch
meisterhaft also das Spiel mit den med
in das Spiel mit den Bildern das hat sie
gut drauf und ich finde das auch mal
ganz klar zu sagen und ich glaube das
siehst du auch so auf eine Art und Weise
ist das was Annalena baerbock macht
sehr wie soll man sagen ja unorthodox
und auf der anderen Seite auch sehr
erfrischend ja das kann man auch so wäre
dass man sich ja so kann man das sehen
aber das Interessante ist ja dass man
sich darüber unterhalten muss ob der
Kurs der hier gefahren wird und der
besteht natürlich sehr stark darin zu
moralisieren und eben andere Länder zu
belehren darüber hatten wir gesprochen
und das den halte ich für strategisch
falsch
also ich glaube dass wir im Umgang mit
China uns keinen Gefallen haben tun
Drohungen auszusprechen zum Beispiel das
hatte ich klar kritisiert oder das
Formulierung benutzt hat wo sie Russland
den Krieg erklärt hat war ein ziemliches
Zeichen von fehlender Diplomatie
aufpassen ne hat sie auch nicht gesagt
sie hat gesagt wir befinden uns in einem
Krieg mit Russland was ja was anderes
offiziell ja aber wenn die
Außenministerin sagt wir sind im Krieg
in Russland und die offizielle Linie ist
das nicht so zu sagen oder so zu sehen
dann kann man sich vorstellen wie sich
das von russischer Seite anhört nämlich
schon als indirekte Kriegserklärung
zumindestens keine keine großen Leistung
ja das stimmt Propaganda nimmt das
natürlich und es an gefunden
muss man sich überlegen ob man das macht
ja aber nur eine Sache will ich trotzdem
einmal sagen es gibt also ich teile das
voll und ganz und ich finde über die
grundsätzliche Linie kann man wirklich
streiten und es ist eine Frage auch
Verwaltung sozusagen wie man da reingeht
und dann weiß man auch ungefähr was man
in welcher Situation sagt ich meine
diese Szene deinen Straßburg wo sie sagt
wir befinden uns in einer Art Krieg mit
Russland ich noch mal ich will das nicht
verteidigen aber ich will nur sagen
manchmal muss man auch sozusagen die
Menschen auch mal Menschen sein lassen
also da ist jemand der ist unter enormer
Anspannung der schläft monatelang
ungefähr vier Stunden am Stück wenn es
hoch kommt der der weiß manchmal gar
nicht mehr in welcher Zeitzone er gerade
unterwegs ist dann muss er auf Englisch
formulieren und dann rutscht dir so
einen Satz raus von dem eigentlich bei
bei sozusagen bei bei wohlwollender
Betrachtung jeder genau weiß wie er
gemeint ist wirklich also ich würde mal
sagen Fehler machen alle und das Amt ist
aus Ministers ist das dass du völlig
recht dass er das letzte an was ich
haben wollte allein die körperliche
strapazze die damit einher geht es
wahrscheinlich von allen politischen
Ämtern die größte genau und das kann ich
alles nachvollziehen trotzdem
wünscht man sich in so einer Situation
einen Hans Dietrich Genscher oder ein
Frank-Walter Steinmeier den sowas nicht
passiert wäre
ja möglicherweise wobei in diesen Zeiten
Außenministerin zu sein Story noch mal
eine ganz besondere Herausforderung und
jetzt haben wir über lavrov in Badehose
ja noch gar nicht gesprochen ja das sind
die sozusagen auch die Dinge die du
ertragen musst aber ich glaube das ist
eine Zeit kommen in der ganz ganz viel
Fingerspitzengefühl gefordert ist also
ich glaube wir müssen umgekehrt sein
also es gibt ja Leute die ihre Politik
mögen und sagen sie sagt ja wenigstens
was sie denkt oder klare Kante und so
weiter und ich frage mich und darüber
haben wir ja beim letzten Mal geredet ob
das wirklich das Gebot der Stunde ist
oder ob das Gebot der Stunde nicht
letztlich darin besteht in einer Uni hin
völlig aufgeheizten Weltlage so sehr so
stark wie möglich zu deeskalieren und
weitere Konfrontationen zu vermeiden das
ist meine Ansicht dazu und aus diesem
Unbehagen was ich habe weil ich glaube
dass wir da viel falsch machen ja als
meine Kritik gekommen und auch die ein
oder andere flopsige Bemerkung ja wie
geht es mir ja nicht um die Person
Anna-Lena Werbung die ich in meinem
Leben noch nie getroffen habe sondern
letztlich geht es mir um eine aus meiner
meinem Verständnis im falsche
Ausrichtung der Außenpolitik ja und
darüber finde ich kann man auch wirklich
gut streiten und ich will es dann an dem
Punkt meine ausdrückliche Lanze für dich
brechen ähm ich erlebe das selber in im
Umfeld der Sendung also es gibt und das
sagt keiner wirklich so offiziell aber
aus der ersten Reihe der Politik erlebe
ich ständig
entscheidende Menschen auch aus anderen
Parteien die unglaublich hardern mit
diesem Kurs und die sagen was
zerschlagen wir da alles gerade der an
Porzellan auf
diplomatischen Parkett und wie wie wohl
Fall sind wir da wie wie unerträglich
ist unsere Doppelmoral also wie Geiseln
die die Menschenrechtssituation in Katar
und dann fährt aber gleichzeitig Robert
Habeck dahin und versucht irgendwie
lng-deals klar zu machen das gleiche
auch mit China ja also dass das große
Wehklagen über die Situation der
deutschen Autoindustrie das entscheidet
sich gerade in China und wenn Du Dir mal
die die verzweifelte Situation vor allen
Dingen von VW z.B an guckst die
runtergerauscht sind von einem
Marktanteil der mal bei 90% lag und
heute sind sie bei
2,4%, was die E-Mobilität angeht das ist
aber die Mobilität die in China gerade
mit einer so bahnbrechenden
Geschwindigkeit weiterentwickelt wird
das klar ist wenn du dieses Rennen
verlierst verlierst du das Rennen
insgesamt ja ein Punkt will ich noch
ganz kurz machen Richard weißt du was
mir bei dieser Kritik aufgefallen ist du
hast ja schon mal sehr
verliert und klar auch den gerade eben
gelobten Frank-Walter Steinmeier hier
kritisiert
über seinen Brahma basierenden Stil
geredet ich habe ihn ja als
Außenminister sehr geschätzt ja und ich
finde ihn sozusagen in seiner Haltung in
dieser dieser über theologischen Haltung
also so eine Art Ersatz Papst quasi ja
so ähnlich habe ich dann habe ich das
beschrieben also dieser theologische
singen sagen stört und da habe ich jetzt
auch sagen wir mal die eine oder ein
rollige Formulierung benutzt und darüber
hat sich niemand aufgeregt genau weil er
ein alter weißer Mann ist so einen alten
weißen Mann den kann man auch schon mal
ein bisschen angehen das das fand ich so
interessant also du hast doch nicht
Annalena baerbock als Frau kritisiert
ausdrücklich wir haben aber so
ausdrücklich dass ich gesagt wörtlich
gesagt dass das genau das gleiche
gleiche Kritik hätte ich auch ja wenn
Sie ein Mann wäre wörtlich gesagt und
ich meine jetzt so eine so eine Wall um
sie zu machen weil sie eine Frau ist
widerspricht der Gleichberechtigung ich
bin der Sohn ich bin der Sohn ich bin
der Sohn einer Feministin der ersten
Stunde meine Mutter war Anfang der 70er
Jahre in der Frauenbewegung die ganzen
70er Jahre hindurch und hat auch sehr
sehr viele
immer situationsziele versucht in
unserer Familie zu verwirklichen
[Musik]
Männerbild bei uns sondern genau das
Gegenteil ja mein Vater war alles andere
als ein ein Macho wir waren ja ein
materialchat und mir ist ein sehr
positives Frauenbild vermittelt worden
und was interessant ist ist damals war
sie hieß gleich Berechtigung der Frau im
Prinzip auch gleich Behandlung das heißt
Männer dürfen Männer kritisieren ja
Frauen dürfen Frauen kritisieren ja
Frauen dürfen Männer kritisieren ja aber
wieso dürfen dann heute Männer keine
Frauen kritisieren
also die Gleichberechtigung ist dann
erreicht wenn man im öffentlichen Raum
in Kontroversen mit Frauen genauso
umgeht wie mit Männern dann ist die
erreicht und nicht wenn man sagt ja
Moment Moment für Frauen gelten
Sonderrechte das ist keine
Gleichberechtigung
nicht unter Artenschutz gestellt werden
dann kriegen sie so ein
sonderbehandlungsstatus der der
Gleichberechtigung der Emanzipation
völlig widerspricht also der wäre so
argumentiert der weiß der Sache der der
Frauen ein jedes im Grunde geht es da
darum dass es egal sein muss genau das
ist meine Haltung genauso bin ich
erzogen aber ich fand das interessant
dieser Reflex der kommt dann sofort ne
das ließ sich wunderbar wieder diese
Front aufbauen so der der alte weiße
Mann und dann geht er auf diese Frau los
und so weiter und dann Sexismus und das
ganze Thema ich wahnsinn das befremdlich
ja das tut unserer öffentlichen
Diskussion nicht gut ja Frauen und
Männer sollen
auseinanderzubringen das ist auch nicht
gut ne und ich finde auch wer man ist
abhängig zu machen vom Alter und vom
Geschlecht
das ist eigentlich klassisch rechts ja
also jemand ist Psyche zu Biologie
sichern das ist klassisch rechts dass
man sagt das ist eine andere Rasse oder
das ist eine Frau und kein Mann und was
passiert das ist klassisch schlechtes
denken hier überhaupt moralische Linien
einzuziehen und ich verstehe nicht wie
Menschen die sich für links halten ja
sich solcher rechten den graster
bedienen wenn auch unter umgekehrten
Vorzeichen also das mache
ist Gleichberechtigung und
grundsätzliche gleich Anerkennung aber
eben auch gleichbar Behandlung in
Kontroversen ich finde das macht ja
eigentlich besonders perfide und es
macht macht sozusagen die andere Seite
dann auch so hilflos und dann steht auch
so ein Frust das merke ich irgendwie
auch bei bei Männern häufig dieses und
das ist auch so Lebensgefühl dass
Friedrich Merzig ganze Zeit versucht so
Gefühl sprechen ja so der der kommt so
der kommt so eine so eine so eine
irgendwann so eine Haltung raus dass man
sagt tue ich ich möchte als Mann nicht
ständig nur noch das Problem sein und in
einer Welt leben in der Männer immer das
Problem und Frauen prinzipiell die
Lösung sind ja weil so einfach ist das
alles nicht und und wie gesagt das
Wissen Millionen von Frauen auch viele
finden das doch genauso die finden
unglaublich viele Frauen die diese Art
von Argumentation lächerlich finden
genau also jemand der so spricht spricht
ja nicht für die Frauen nee tut er nicht
weißt du was ein schöner Gedanke noch
nur und dann lassen wir das Thema auch
ein schöner Gedanke ich habe neulich an
interview gehört mit seiner marien der
gerade abgebildeten finnischen
Regierungschefin ist eine sehr
bemerkenswerte Frau und ich oute mich
quasi als als Gruppe als Fanboy von
seiner marien
die neulich etwas total schönes sagte
und das wirklich einfach mal zum hin
bleiben und irgendwo hinhängen auf die
Frage wie sie es denn hält mit Gendern
und wie sieht diese ganze
identitätspolitische Diskussion verfolgt
und so weiter und das dritte Geschlecht
und ja das ganze das ganze Thema
genderfluid und so sagte sie einfach
weißt du es ist ganz einfach wir sind
Finnland wir sind ein kleines Land und
wir brauchen jeden und es mir völlig
egal ob das Mann ist eine Frau ist ob
der transsexuell oder asexuell oder
bisexuell oder homosexuell ist ist mir
alles völlig egal wir brauchen jeden in
dieser Gesellschaft weil wir nur
zusammen wirklich was reißen können als
kleines Land und deswegen ist jeder
einzelne genauso wie er ist herzlich
willkommen und das ist halt der
Gegenantwort zu diesem ewigen Menschen
Geschlechter alte weiße Männer gegen
Frauen und so weiter in Front zu bringen
oder eine gute Gesellschaft sind
gesellschaftlich an allen Ecken und
Enden Feinde richtig richtig also du
bist wieder ein vollwertiges Mitglied
dieser Gesellschaft Richard für mich
immer gewesen freue mich sehr darüber
aber dieses Thema finde ich gut links
rechts du sagst dieses alte Schema
greift nicht mehr gibt's das eigentlich
überhaupt noch links rechts also wenn
dich jemand fragt und ich nehme doch
anders bist du häufig gefragt wo du dich
politisch vor Ort hast wirst du
wahrscheinlich nicht beantworten in
welcher welcher welche Partei du gewählt
hast aber man wird ja versuchen
irgendein statementiert
ja wo du dich irgendwie zugehörig fühlst
oder so für die könntest du dich in
irgendwas einsortieren nee ehrlich
gesagt nein geht mir nämlich den vielen
Gründen genauso und ich fühle mich da
ein klein bisschen Geistes verwandt mit
Helmut Schmidt ja der der ja mal dieses
schöne Zitat hat gesagt hat wenn ich
mich selbst Frage ob ich ein Linker bin
so müsste ich sagen wahrscheinlich denn
ich stimme überein mit dem Fortschritt
in der sozialen Demokratie aber ich
müsste erkennen dass ich auch an manchen
Tendenzen und Auffassungen in der FDP
und in der CDU Gefallen finde wir im
Grundsatz alles ablehnen wollte was die
gegnerische Partei tut und denkt der
wäre wohl im eigentlichen Wort Sinn
reaktionär
das heißt also mit anderen Worten ja man
passt doch nicht in eine Schachtel mit
all dem wie man ist was man ist und so
weiter und mir geht das da genauso also
ich habe
Berührungspunkte mit
konservativen Politikern wo ich in
anderen Punkten gänzlich anderer Meinung
bin ja und ich bin als Linker
sozialisiert und es gibt viele Dinge die
heute für links gelten ja mit denen ich
wenig anfangen kann
zum Beispiel also was mich bei vielen
linken heute stört
sind Dinge die ich für erste
Weltprobleme halte ja und die nicht was
mit mit mit realer Not und mit Leid und
sowas zu tun haben wie zum Beispiel die
Genderfrage so und da ist dabei wäre die
Antwort ganz einfach die eine Hälfte der
Gesellschaft muss ertragen ja dass sie
einen Gendern und die andere Hälfte muss
ertragen dass die anderen das nicht tun
genau aber hier jetzt ein ideologischen
Kampf zu machen dass das alles sofort
sein muss ich mag sowieso diese Kultur
der sofort ist nicht ja ich finde etwas
das moralisch nicht in Ordnung ist das
muss jetzt sofort geändert werden das
ist eigentlich Konsumverhalten wo ich
irgendwie per Mausklick und Druck und so
weiter oder als Kunde ja sofort
irgendwie das haben will und das und das
extra noch so ich finde das ist kein
angemessene ethische Haltung moralischer
Fortschritt braucht Zeit und moralischer
Fortschritt braucht Zustimmung und das
kann man nicht von oben vor ordnen oder
indem man jetzt an einer Universität
oder wie auch immer parole ausgeht man
gendert und wenn man das nicht macht
dann macht man was falsch und das sind
Dinge wo ich einfach damit fremde weil
diese Leute die das machen sich selbst
als links verstehen und ich überhaupt
nicht sicher bin ob das eigentlich
wirklich links ist ja und nicht einfach
eine falsche Strategie und deswegen
würde ich sagen ich kann mich in diesem
Spektrum nicht einfach mal irgendwo
verorten und sage ich gehe eindeutig zu
denen und denen dazu interessante nimm
Zusammenhang ist ja diese diese
Sehnsucht irgendwie nach Friedrich Merz
dieses Jahr gibt irgendwie in der
deutschen Politik und in in vielen
Bereichen der Gesellschaft also
einerseits diese harte Ablehnung was
auch interessant ist und andererseits
sozusagen diese die Sehnsucht der
Friedrich Merz ja ja
kommodischen Typus ist genau
alles wofür die CDU früher stand
Klarheit auch in der Orientierung also
eine neue Ordentlichkeit die irgendwie
verloren gegangen ist im Sinne von
danach weißt du wieder wo links ist wo
rechts ist kannst das ganz klar die
konservative nennen sich ja nicht mehr
rechts ne und spätestens als die AFD
gibt kann man das auch nicht mehr aber
könntest du genauso wie man sagt
Friedrich Merz sozusagen die die
Verkörperung eines konservativen ich
würde sagen Wolfgang Schäuble ja
verkörper genau konservativen was
relativ selten geworden ist in der CDU
und könntest du umgekehrt sagen wer für
dich die Verkörperung eines linken
Politikers ist weißt du was Verrücktes
jetzt hätte ich und ich glaube ganz
vielen geht so die würden jetzt sagen
Sahra Wagenknecht die vorzeige linke
aber dass mich nicht mehr kompliziert
geworden genau weil wir neben dem das
ist meine These ja schön
stell dir mal mein Modell vor wir haben
also rechts und links sind ich völlig
tot ja aber sie werden durch etwas
anderes überschattet sie werden
überschattet durch dadurch dass wir eine
große Zahl von Menschen haben die sich
in ihrer politischen Ausrichtung in der
Mitte orientiert
deren Kompass das ist so und die findest
du in der CDU in der FDP in der SPD und
bei den Grünen alle die Parteien wollen
die Mitte besetzen und ihre Wähler
wollen auch das Gefühl haben in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft zu sein dass man
dann böswig Mainstream oder so unendlich
ja das ist aber man kann sagen
das sind eher die Konformisten und dann
gibt es die non-konformisten das sind
die die grundsätzlich immer gegen die
Positionen der Mitte sind die also in
der Mitte Misstrauen die dem
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
Misstrauen die glauben dass man ständig
belogen wird die denken das was die
Mehrheit denkt muss immer falsch sein
und so weiter Leute die mir am Flughafen
zu Raunen erzählen Sie doch im Fernsehen
mal die Wahrheit ja so und dann hat sich
dann hat er wieder drei Viertel auf der
einen Seite
ungefähr dreiviertel und ein Viertel
einmal stark wachsen seit Corona auf der
anderen Seite das quasi das was Konsens
ist oder weitgehende Konsens oder vor
einigen medialer Konsens ist bezweifeln
und ich glaube diese Trennung ist
entstanden durch die sozialen Medien
weil die Leitmedien ja die verkörpern
nahezu sämtlich die konformistische
Position und die sozialen Medien sind
ein hummelplatz der Nonnen konform ist
und diese Frage schneller radikale bitte
und der Mehrheit glaubst du was da
erzählt wird oder hast du Zweifel und so
das ist fast stärker in der Gesellschaft
als diese Links rechts
thematisch auch und deswegen kann das
sein dass Berührungspunkte zwischen
Sahra Wagenknecht und den rechten
bestehen ohne dass man deswegen Sarah
Wagenknecht ein rechte Gesinnung an
dichten sollte genau aber sie kriegt
erstaunlich viel Applaus von der AFD
weil sie sich traut die Mitte massiv zu
kritisieren und in dem Punkt sind sich
die ganzen neuen Konformisten egal ob
sie sich als rechts oder links
einsortieren eben einig ja es
interessant also die die diese diese
klare Einsortierung gibt es irgendwie
nicht mehr ich weiß ich habe mit Gemüse
mir schon vor langer Zeit mal darüber
gesprochen er sagte deshalb alles Gesäß
Geographie politische gesehen ist
Geographie ja dieses links rechts und so
weiter das ist das greift alles viel zu
kurz und viel zu wenig aber es
interessant ist es scheint eben deswegen
habe ich vorhin auch diesen Begriff
benutzt eine Sehnsucht nach so einer
Ordentlichkeit im deutschen
Parteiensystem zu geben ja dass dieses
links rechts wieder geht doch immer noch
da muss ich das überlegen also ich
plädiere für die ultimative Abschaffung
es gibt in der politischen
Berichterstattung noch den Begriff
bürgerliches Lager und da sind die CDU
und die FDP gemeint und die grüne grüne
nicht gleich die Grünen ultra
bürgerliche Partei sie sind sozusagen
das Bürgertum ihrer Generation meistens
ein bisschen jünger als das konservative
Bürgertum aber das ist doch ein Witz die
als nicht bürgerliche Partei ja also
jenseits des bürgerlichen Lagers zu
sehen die Grünen sind ja auch eine
zutiefst konservative Partei und es war
im Wort sind also wenn es jedoch um die
Bewahrung der Natur der Schöpfung geht
dann bist du konservativ und zwar im
besten Sinne ist doch gar keine Frage
und zwar der Grund warum ich damals als
ich anfing politisch laufen zu lernen
mit 17 18 zum ersten Mal konnte
natürlich die Grünen gewählt habe
aus meinem großen Thema Umwelt und
Naturschutz heraus ich war im
reinischbergischen Naturschutzverband
Folge beobachten
für Wasseramseln
über den Grünen nicht ganz so hoch im
Kurs ne da gab es also also viele die
die erste Meinung davon hatten hier
sozusagen Gefängniswärter der Schöpfung
daran gesehen haben aber aber auf jeden
Fall dieses starke Interesse an Natur
weil die Tieren und so weiter ne und
dann in dieses konservative das war das
was ich an den Grünen ja immer sehr
gemacht habe ja die sehr interessante
diese
Links rechts dieses links rechts Schema
geht zurück auf die Französische
Revolution ne genau
Freunde
genau so und das zieht sich sehr lange
durch und man kann sagen es gibt ja da
unterscheidungspunkte die man so
grundsätzlich für rechts und links
machen kann also links bedeutet
eigentlich der Idee nach auf der Seite
der schwachen zustehen richtig rechts
bedeutet eher auf der Seite der
herrschenden der starken etablierten zu
stehen also durch die Geschichte durch
ne von der französischen Revolution bis
ins 20 Jahrhundert hinein das war ja
eine ganz wichtige Trennlinie dann war
links die Partei des Fortschritts
klassisch und rechts
progressiv und rechts waren die die den
Fortschritt aufhalten wollten und die
bestehenden Ordnung verteidigten also
die Links waren die Gewerkschaften
wählen durften dass sie Melonen bekamen
besser Arbeitsbedingungen und so die
wollten ja die Gesellschaft weiter
drehen immer in einer andere
Gesellschaft und es ist ja auch so ja
die Gesellschaft ist immer von links
weitergeht worden in der Geschichte
und es ist von der konservativen Seite
immer versucht auszubremsen und zu sagen
das was wir bei das Lebensgefühl
dahinter steht das was wir jetzt haben
ist doch gut
wenn ihr das weitergeht dann wird das
nur ganz schlimm der der Satz dazu ist
eigentlich früher war eigentlich alles
besser ne ja früher früher war alles
besser und es geht hier eben den
konservativen ums bewahren genau und
dann eben nicht nur bewahren des Waldes
wir sollen halt eben auch zu bewahren
der sittlichen Ordnung
des gesellschaftlichen Ausgleich wir
besteht und so weiter und das ist ja im
Grunde genommen ist das ja keine
Überzeugung und was dahinter ist ein
Gefühl ein Lebensgefühl nein genau links
ist dieses Lebensgefühl alles muss
anders werden klassischerweise ja alles
muss gerechter sozialer und so weiter
werden rechts und rechts oder
konservativ was ja früher das gleiche
war ja war dieses bloß keine Experimente
wie das mal auf dem Wahlplakat ja
sondern die Dinge bewahren und so wenig
wie möglich verändern das ist so die
eigentliche alte Achse das hat da ist
natürlich viel mit passiert ne aber das
ist eigentlich dass das Urgefühl genau
und weißt du was den gerade drüber nach
was eigentlich total interessant ist ist
folgendes und ich glaube daraus kommt
auch so diese Idee quasi links predigen
und rechts leben ja links reden rechts
leben also
für Naturschutz zu sein und so weiter
aber gleichzeitig mit dem SUV dann vor
die Kita ja und in bioladenfahrt fahren
und und gar kein Problem mit diesem
Widerspruch zu haben und interessant ist
eigentlich folgendes wenn du also links
bedeutet doch eigentlich in dem Gefühl
der meisten Menschen
moralisch makellos zu sein ne du bist
immer für die guten du bist du bist
Vergleich halten
genau und gleichzeitig aber gibt es und
das siehst du ja zum Beispiel auch bei
Kindern Menschen sind auf einer Art
wahnsinnig konservative Wesen und
deswegen und hat und haben so eine
Sehnsucht danach dass die Dinge bleiben
wie sie sind was dann auch dazu führt
dass diese Globalisierung diese
gigantischen Umwälzungen die wir erlebt
haben in den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten ja für die einen ich würde
sagen für Menschen wie Dich und mich
eine gigantische Chance für mich war
sozusagen die Möglichkeit aus aus meinem
kleinen Südtiroler bergteil rauszukommen
und wirklich die Welt zu erobern zu
entdecken
fremde Menschen fremde Länder
kennenzulernen fremde Kulturen zu
erleben ich habe das immer als
wahnsinnig bereichernd empfunden und
andere wiederum die auch aus meiner
Generation die das als bedrohlich
empfinden die die Globalisierung auch
als bedrohliche empfinden das heißt
diese Sehnsucht dass die Dinge so
bleiben wie sie sind und in diesem
Widerspruch einerseits sozusagen
moralisch sauber zu sein wir sind
natürlich für Gleichheit und
Gerechtigkeit und alle Menschen und so
weiter und auf der anderen Seite aber
bitte nicht zu viel davon lass doch
einfach mal Dinge überfordern mich nicht
und und diesen Konflikt sieht man doch
da auch den bilden doch letzten Endes
auch Parteien ab ne deswegen ist kein
Problem zu sagen Grün zu wählen
gleichzeitig sehr bürgerlich wenn man
heute sagen würde sehr konservativ zu
sein Winfried Kretschmann z.B der sagt
das ja auch der Inbegriff eines
konservative
verirrt genau naja
werden
Kretschmann war früher Mao ist also der
war sozusagen ultra ultra ultra links
genau sowas von zutiefst peinlich dass
er der Inbegriff des Konservativismus
geworden ist richtig aber was ich sagen
wollte also die Linken haben immer die
Moral gepachtet und die Rechten oder die
Konservativen die guten Sittensen
Höflichkeit und sowas alles ne wo die
liegen immer weniger wert draufgelegt
haben
sexuelle Verkommenheit habe ich jetzt
her gedacht waren
oben ohne glaube ich kennst du kennst du
den Song noch ich kenne mich an einige
Fendrich Songs erinnern die Weltklasse
naja ich kann mich kann mich an den
Machos Song erinnern Macho Macho
Macho
zurück was ich natürlich verändert hat
und das ist wichtig ich sag ja so sehr
bei den einen ist das sozusagen
verändern die Linken ja die ganze Welt
verändern und mit vielen Rosinen im Kopf
zum Teil und auf der anderen Seite die
sagen komm komm komm immer halblang
machen und so ja das wird nur schlimmer
jetzt hat sich natürlich was verändert
die haben immer gesagt wir müssen die
Welt Revolution machen
jetzt wurde die Weltrevolution
tatsächlich gemacht aber nicht
Gewerkschaftsführer oder
Parteifunktionäre haben die Welt
Revolution gemacht und schon gar nicht
das Proletariat oder um die das Volk
sondern die Weltrevolution hat das
Kapital gemacht das Kapital also unsere
Wirtschaften ja das Geld die
Finanzströme ja das alles hat die ganze
Welt umgeflüchtet die Globalisierung ja
die Digitalisierung als neue Form davon
es gibt nichts revolutionäreres als das
Kapital und jetzt haben Leute die in der
CDU sind das große Problem auf der einen
Seite gibt es da häufig eben dieses
gemütskonservative und auf der anderen
Seite ist man eigentlich Teil je nach
Partei die genau diesen Prozess enorm
unterstützt weil er natürlich auch zu
unserem Wohlstand geführt hat und
Deutschlands wirtschaftliche Stärke ist
die Grundlage unseres Wohlstandes
und das ist ja eigentlich eine nicht so
ganz leicht auszuhaltende innere Balance
konservativ alles soll beim Alten
bleiben und durch durch durch die
Globalisierung und durch die
Digitalisierung bleibt gar nichts beim
alten sondern alles wie ändert sich
immer schneller genau ja das ist genau
dieses Gefühl über das ich auch gerade
gesprochen habe ne dieses deswegen denke
ich manchmal so diese diese Welt in der
in der ich aufgewachsen bin 80er Jahre
du auch wird da war da war die Welt
vereinfacht das war klar zwei starke
Pole da waren also da war der
Sozialismus der Kommunismus dass das
Reich des Bösen die so wird Union und
auf der anderen Seite die guten die Amis
ja es war alles irgendwie klar wobei
wenn man ich finde es immer interessant
wenn man heute auf die Zeit guckt ne ja
dann ist es interessant dass das mit dem
Kommunismus in der Sowjetunion
eigentlich nicht anders war als mit dem
Kommunismus in China heute also ich
glaube ich habe meinen es ja geschrieben
der ist war Stalin Kommunist
und das war kein Witz sondern ich meine
das ernst also die Frage ob Hitler
Nationalsozialist ist die muss man sich
nicht stellen weil er hat ja
Nationalsozialismus in dieser Mischung
überhaupt erst erfunden ja der wollte
wissen muss also der der sowjetische
Kommunismus wurde von Linien erfunden
nicht von Stalin und Stalin war einer
jener dreckigen Trittbrettfahrer die in
jedem Herrschaftssystem sich auf miese
Art und Weise an die Macht gebracht
hätten und die wahrscheinlich so zynisch
waren dass sie gar keine politischen
Überzeugung hatten dann kam mit
krustchoff wieder jemand der in die
Überlegenheit der Sowjetunion geglaubt
hat ja an Überlegenheit des Kommunismus
und das Gesellschaftsmodells und dann
war Schluss also mit brechen hier auf
angefangen hat wahrscheinlich keinen
sowjetischer
Staatsführer mehr an die Überlegenheit
des Kommunismus oder das
Gesellschaftsmodells geklaut von allem
was nur noch konservativ dann ging es
nur noch mit eiserner Hand das was man
hatte die Staaten die man als was sollen
erobert hatte ja und den Status Quo den
man hatte zu verhalten ja das heißt also
fortschrittliche im ging da ja überhaupt
gar keine von aus also das was
eigentlich links ausgemacht haben sollte
ja und wenn du es mal weiter denkst du
das sind total interessanter Gedanke ich
meine hising Ping ist das ein Kommunist
ja ich habe ja beim letzten Mal gesagt
ich glaube der hat keine Weltanschauung
ich glaube aber der kann verschiedene
Karten ziehen ja genau die er fürs
Regieren braucht ja das ist das was ich
persönlich glaube ja ohne ich weil ich
bin immer nie begegnet und werde ihm die
begegnen ja aber ich denke immer dass
auch dahinter hinter all diesen
Ideologien es gibt noch
schöneres Wort als Ideologien das heißt
derivationen ja jede Geschichte braucht
jedes Land braucht eine Geschichte die
sie zusammenhält
oder starke Geschichten sozusagen ja
leider Erzählung ja eine große Erzählung
ohne große Erzählungen fliegen Länder
auseinander das ist eine eine
Feststellung Anfang des 19 Jahrhunderts
von dem Italiener Pareto wilfredo Pareto
viele kennen die
ferrito-prinzip genau bedeutet
diese Woche in der Sendung darüber
gesprochen
eines Gesamtaufwandes ja eigentlich nur
die echte Veränderung hervorbringt ja
das heißt also von dem 100% deines
Aufwandes nämlich 80% fruchtlos und nur
20% entscheiden nachher darüber über den
Erfolg einer Sache richtig und dieser
wilfredo Pareto der politisch auch
konservativ war aber auf eine ganz
eigene Art und Weise der hat eben gesagt
Gesellschaften müssen durch die
irrationen zusammengehalten werden also
ich große Erzählung heute sagen wir
narrative jedes narrativ ist natürlich
irgendwo eine Lüge ne verkürzt so und in
einer einseitige Betrachtung und so
weiter aber ohne das kann man halt nicht
regieren also ich finde die die die also
eines ist keine Lüge nämlich dass die
Bayern natürlich die besten sind
sagt die CSU du meinst aber nicht den FC
Bayern der gerade nicht so wäre ganz so
sehr zu den Besten gehört ja eigentlich
will aber ist das nicht das ist ein das
ist doch ein total interessantes
narrativen Erzählungen ja genau ist
eines der erfolgreichsten narrative der
Nazis Geschichte und ich finde das super
ich finde das gut das ist das gibt das
ist so identitätsstiften das finden alle
anderen dann die nervt das nicht gegeben
den Leuten auf den Kekse damit aber das
ist einer der größten Johannes Rau
diesen Slogan erfunden hat wir in
Nordrhein-Westfalen genau ja und das war
irgendwie immer komisch ja dieses Wappen
ja mit Pferd und rein die nicht
zusammenpassen und dann die
karnevalswitze übereinander und so ja
ich meine dieses wirgefühl gibt's
vielleicht in der Arbeiterschaft oder
gab es im urgebiet also wir im
Ruhrgebiet das hat glaube ich ähnlich
wie mir das an mir funktioniert ja
richtig aber wir in Nordrhein-Westfalen
ja es ist Düsseldorf und Herne
geht nicht zusammen und das spüren die
Leute ja auch sofort aber in Bayern geht
das zusammen das total interessant wie
dieses dieses dieses Land sich an dieser
Erzählung immer so aufrichtet und man
hat dann das Gefühl die der kommt dann
auch so dieser trotz durch und jetzt
zeigen wir es euch mal und es macht die
so erfolgreich am Ende macht ihr noch
unabhängig fällt mir gerade ein das
mindestens so erfolgreich wie mir von
mir ist in Deutschland sagt dass der
Kölner Lokal Patriotismus ja genau ich
habe ja schon häufiger darüber
gesprochen über freiheitszustand der
Welt ja und deswegen ist sie so
lebenswert
zumindestens im Karneval und in manchen
anderen Situationen also ich ich zitiere
immer gerne Tommy Engel der gesagt hat
es gibt 2000 Lieder über Köln und keins
über Leverkusen
und ich glaube dass Köln wahrscheinlich
die meisten besuchenste Stadt der Welt
ist weil wir geben Karneval natürlich
neue Lieder geschrieben werden richtig
wahrscheinlich Paris und New York längst
überholt haben
dafür trainiert das auch dieses narrativ
wir sind Kölner klar wir sind irgendwie
katholisch aber wir halten uns nicht
dran also dieser rheinische
Katholizismus sie sind Frohnaturen wir
sind gastfreundlich wir sind weltoffen
und so weiter funktioniert unglaublich
gut
Deutschland hätte so eine relativ wollte
ich gerade sagen und das ist doch das
fehlt doch gerade im Moment so sehr
diese große Erzählung die uns alle
irgendwie zusammenhält und die kann man
nicht am reisbret Denken ne das musst
Kultur heraus erwachsen ja und jetzt das
auf mein Gedanke dazu ich wenn man wenn
man sich das so anschaut wir reden ja
häufig über die Polarisierung in dieser
Gesellschaft wir haben über Amerika
häufig gesprochen wir haben darüber
gesprochen dieses
in den USA reden mehr davon dass es
eigentlich du sagtest von Lebensgefühl
da redet man davon dass es eigentlich um
Stammes Zugehörigkeit geht erinnerst du
dich Capitol ja und dann der Mann mit
den Hörnern der da rein ging der
büffelmaske so und da dachte ich so und
jetzt genau das ist es
Stammeszugehörigkeit ja die Codes die
Sprache einzelne Begriffe darum geht's
und deswegen war es auch nie ein
Widerspruch dass so ein Typ wie Trump
der ja überhaupt gar nichts mit den
Leuten die er anspricht zu tun hat der
ein zynischer Sack ist um es mal
deutlich erfolgreicher Stammesführer so
und die haben den das geglaubt und es
war weil er diese kurz beherrscht weil
er diese Ruhe Sprache beherrscht weil
dann sagte das ist Lockerung Talk ja
wenn ich rap dann bei der Pussy sage und
so weiter das ist überhaupt kein Problem
so reden wir Jungs unter uns das ist
perfekt genau dieses Lebensgefühl
getroffen sagen ja na klar aber doch
alles schon gemacht was trinkst du dich
eigentlich auf ne
ja also seid ihr 90er Jahren kann ich
mich erinnern gibt's diesen Begriff des
Tribalismus wieder in der Politik also
der Stamm ist zugehörig genau damals
bestanden große Ängste dass du das so
die Gegenbewegung zur Globalisierung der
Tribalismus ist und man muss ganz
ehrlich sagen es ist nicht die
Gegenbewegung das ist die Rückseite der
Medaille richtig weil die Globalisierung
so schnell genau und sich die
Lebenskultur der Menschen schneller
geändert hat als je in der Geschichte ja
nicht zuletzt nachher durch die
Einführung des Smartphones und das
Internet und so weiter weil das alles so
schnell geht suchen sich die Menschen
Schlupflöcher ja Zugehörigkeiten
überschaubare Zugehörigkeit ja und das
kann in dem einen oder anderen Fall
können das quasi Stimme sein jetzt
können wir lange drüber nachdenken was
es noch alles für Stimme gibt irgendwas
sozusagen dazu gehört also wichtiges
standesverhalten ist zum Beispiel der
Fußballverein richtig ne also steh auf
wenn du ein Schalker bist ist der
reinstet muss ja immer zusammen der
Schalker oder man gehört alle anderen
müssen Wasser kreiert werden so das was
ich für Schalke gesagt hat geht
natürlich für jede anderen Fußballverein
auch genau also diese Fangesänge
beschwören ja tribalistische
Zusammengehörigkeit und es ist ja
wahnsinnig schön wenn das sich im
Fußball ereignet und nicht in der
Politik aber wir haben auch in der
Politik zunehmend die Tendenzen die
Rückseite der Globalisierung ist der
Tribalismus also was du da gerade
ansprichst richard ist ja eigentlich so
ein Unbehagen ne dass ich in gewisser
Weise breit gemacht hat man weiß nicht
mehr so ganz genau also Frage was ist
links was ist rechts du weißt nicht mehr
so ganz genau
wohin du eigentlich gehörst wohin diese
Welt läuft wohin denn ganzes Leben läuft
und ich frage mich auch manchmal ob das
mit dem mit dem zweiten großen Thema das
sozusagen darunter liegt oder das
vielleicht sogar über allem schweb zu
tun hat nämlich mit der Frage
dass diese Globalisierung über die wir
gerade gesprochen haben ja im Grunde
auch ein unfassbar harter impact wie man
heute sagen würde ein Einschlag war für
alles was mal
beste Mittelschicht war was
Bürgerlichkeit war
da hat es plötzlich eine Welt getroffen
die keine Gewissheit mehr hat wenn du
heute auch Arzt Ärztin bist wenn du weiß
nicht Anwalt bist wenn du auch diese
Leute kämpfen plötzlich und ich habe
schon das Gefühl durch Corona noch mal
beschleunigt der hat sich die Frage nach
der Orientierung nach dem Sinn plötzlich
ganz neu gestellt und das sind
erstaunlich viele oder besorgen ist
erregend viele die ganz merkwürdig
abgebogen sind ja also die die
Arbeitswelt hat sich durch die Frage
nach dem Sinn durch Corona verstärkt
wurde weil man Zeit hatte über sich und
sein Leben nachzudenken
enorm verändert also ich habe das ja in
meinem Buch über die Arbeit geschrieben
wir gehen von einer klassischen
Arbeitsgesellschaft die wir sie kannten
in eine sinngesellschaftung nur ist
diese sinngesellschaft erstmal dadurch
charakterisiert dass wir keinen
vorgegebenen Sinn hatten ja also über
ewige Zeiten haben die Menschen unter
vorgegebenen Sinn gelebt
das heißt also man hat gesagt gott hat
die Welt geschaffen zu denen und dem
Zweck und du musst ihn immer brav
anbieten und das und das machen wir
weinen ein absoluten ordnungsraum ja so
viel Ordnungsrahmen wie wir heute fast
niemand mehr wieder haben und die ganze
Geschichte der Modernisierung ist das
Aufspringen von ordnungsraum und das
interessant an der deutschen Geschichte
ist das nach 45 ja erst stark in der
katholischen Kirche ja konservative
Moral die ganze Schuld beladene
Generation hat versucht sich ihr Leben
so ordentlich und überschaubar wie
möglich einzurichten das ist sozusagen
die Sehnsucht die man heute hat nach der
guten alten Zeiten
keine Experimente deswegen eben die
Adenauer Zeit ne und Adenauer der eben
unglaublich politischer erfolgreich
waren mehrfach wieder gewählt und auch
seine ganze Politik hat durchsetzen kann
und da gibt es wenn sicherlich bei dem
einen oder anderen eine Sehnsucht danach
wie schön wäre es wenn die Welt wieder
gut geordnet wäre wenn sie wenn sie in
dem Sinne wieder ordentlich ist das ja
so der alte Geist des konservativ
aber sie wissen natürlich alle das ist
in der Geschichte der Menschheit keinen
freiwilliges zurückgibt es gibt keinen
zurück in die Zeit der frisch
gestärktten Hemden der dann
Arbeitszeiten des schlechten Gewissens
der Kriegsgräberfürsorge der Heinz er
hat Witze des fettigen Essens und was
alles dazu gehört hat
und ein Konservativismus für für für die
Zukunft sich auszudenken in einer es ist
rasant verändernden Weltgesellschaft in
der die Themen ja durch durch die
globalen Konflikte von allen Seiten
einprasseln
das ist eigentlich eine nicht zu
schaffende Aufgabe und ich kann mir kaum
vorstellen dass es für die Rolle die
Schäuble oder März spielen und gespielt
haben überhaupt noch ein Nachfolger
geben kann und dann wüsste ich nicht
mehr was die CDU ist bei den Grünen weiß
ich schon lange nicht mehr was das ist
das ist eine andere Partei als die die
in den 80er Jahren anfing
bei der FDP ist die einzige Partei wo
man immer weiß was sie ist ja weil sie
im Zweifels führen für Steuersenkung mit
Eintritt und für die Entlastung des
Mittelstandes das ist sozusagen ein sehr
sehr kleinen Markenkern ich weiß der ist
nur zusammen philosophisch größer aber
er ist in der Praxis immer relativ klein
und die Sozialdemokratie hat ja also
sozusagen ihren großen Aderlass schon
hinter sich ne also die Geschichte der
Sozialdemokratie war ja eine dramatische
abschiedsgeschichte hin zu einer 20%
Vater
inklusive Spaltung und allem
genau weil weil es das Proletariat in
dem Sinne nicht mehr gibt als das
Proletariat zumindestens nicht mehr es
gibt immer noch eine Arbeiterschaft das
ist schon richtig aber eben nicht mehr
das klassische Proletariat und dass die
Leute die an den Universitäten irgendwie
neue Gedanken ausbrüten in der gleichen
Partei waren wie die die im
Kohlekraftwerke arbeitet haben das hat
noch nie wirklich zusammengepasst ne
konnte auch nur durch eine derivation
irgendwie zusammengehalten werden und
diesen Verlust den hat die SPD jetzt
gespürt und weiß was am Ende übrig
bleibt Personen also wenn Sarah
Wagenknecht eine Partei gründet dann ist
das die Wagenknecht verteilt ja wie wie
macron ja auch mache schwarz richtig und
ich denke das Sebastian Kurz möglich ist
Sebastian Kurz auch ja der sozusagen die
Partei als Geisel für sich genommen hat
wie Trump das mit den Republikanern
gemacht hat also am Ende läuft doch
darauf hinaus oder ja das Gefühl habe
ich ganz stark also gerade in einer in
einer
Mediendemokratie die wir sind ja also
Medien spielen eigentlich die
entscheidende Rolle und narrative
Erzählungen über die gerade schon
gesprochen haben ist auch total
interessant ne wenn du wenn du mal
überlegst z.B das das Mega Thema
Migration wenn du das man nimmst und
versuchst mal links und rechts sozusagen
daran fest zu machen da kommt die AFD
wirklich jetzt rechts
die das Thema nimmt und das richtig
rassistisch hochzieht ja dann kommt die
CDU und die sagt wir brauchen 1,5
Millionen Zuwanderung und in die
Arbeitskräfte richtig und dann kommt
Sarah Wagenknecht und sagten ja also das
mit der Zuwanderung das können wir so
nicht weitermachen das geht nicht und
begründet es aber eben nicht rassistisch
wie wie Teile der AFD sondern sie
begründet es mit der sozialen Frage und
aus ihrer Sicht komplett stringent ja
sie sagt pass auf ihr müsst euch doch
mal klar machen unsere Leute die Leute
die uns gewählt haben die sogenannten
kleinen Leute die kämpfen jetzt dort am
am anderen Ende um die günstigen
Wohnungen um die guten Jobs in diesem
ganzen prekären Bereich und so weiter
ihr müsst doch verstehen dass die gerade
in einem echt harten Konkurrenzkampf
plötzlich stehen mit ganz vielen
Menschen die neuen dieses Land kommen
das müsste doch endlich mal kapieren das
ist klassisch links gegen Neulings so ja
also neu links war ja dass man sich vom
Proletariat abgewendet hat weil die
sowieso CDU gewählt haben ja und
Minderheiten entdeckt hat und die
Menschen in der Dritten Welt das ist ja
quasi die
und sie bezieht die klassisch linke
Position das ist darum geht was für die
Schwachen in der deutschen Gesellschaft
wichtig das ist interessant wir haben
beides ist in sich komplett stringent
und logisch und auf eine Art aber dann
trotzdem mit das zusammenbringst
vollkommen widersprüchlich
erklärtskonservativ also ist die
unübersichtliche Gesellschaft ist nicht
etwas was ihr als positives Ziel
vorstellt ja also ich glaube dass sie
an der DDR geschätzt hat dass das ein
übersichtliches lag war und das war es
ja nun wirklich ja und ich denke dass
das so die gemütskern ist das hat jetzt
nichts mit dem politischen System zu tun
hat sie sich jetzt inzwischen so oft von
distanziert aber irgendwo eine eine
Behaglichkeit muss sie obwohl sie ja
Außenseiterin war trotzdem immer
irgendwo wahrgenommen haben und diese
Vorstellung dass wahnsinniger zuzukommen
und das Land in alle Himmelsrichtungen
durcheinander fliegt und die sozialen
Spannungen zunehmen und die Konflikte
und die Rechten dadurch erstarken und so
das will sie glaube ich verhindern also
so habe ich das verstanden Richard
letzte Frage Sahra Wagenknecht von dem
wir uns glaube ich einig sind persönlich
ein sehr nette Person nette Frau mag die
also ich behalte mich gerne mit ihr
unheimlich höflich
zuvorkommend alles was du willst und
trotzdem für dich als politisches
Phänomen wirklich greifbar ist das für
dich eine Überzeugungstäterin ist sie
opportunistin ich halte sie für eine
Überzeugungstäterin ich glaube die kann
gar nicht anders also ich glaube sie ist
tatsächlich
überzeugungs-täterin durch und durch und
dann muss man sagen wenn wir sagen dass
ich rechts links ja nicht komplett
aufgelöst haben aber in vielen Punkten
quasi nicht mehr die richtigen
Schablonen sind
dann befürwortet oder beflügelt das den
politischen Kurs von Sahra Wagenknecht
weil sie sich nie eben nicht in
irgendeinen orthodoxes Spektrum
einreitet das heißt also die Zukunft
vieler Politiker also wenn man sozusagen
als eine Person ja in der Partei gründet
besteht ja darin dass man nicht irgendwo
sicher einsortierbar ist und das muss
nicht nur an einem selber liegen sondern
es kann auch daran liegen dass diese
sortierungskästen einfach nicht mehr
funktionieren und auch nicht mehr so in
die Zeit passen wir leben ja in einer
Zeit in der rechts ein Schimpfwort ist
genau und links ein halbes Schimpfwort
was ist immer schon war ja aber das hat
wieder was mit dem zu tun was sie vorhin
sagte Konformismus noch ein Konformismus
muss wir grenzen sozusagen aus was nicht
Mitte ist es entweder ab ständig als
rechts oder abständig als links und wir
haben ja jetzt gerade analysiert dass
diese rechts links Felder ja in sich
nicht konsistent sind und deswegen tut
man eigentlich diesem Phänomen Sarah
aber eigentlich keinen Gefallen damit
ständig zu gucken was ist an ihr links
oder was ist an ihr Recht ist richtig
ich glaube dass diese diese Begriffe
einfach nicht die richtigen Instrumente
sind um das zu packen
das war spannend vielen Dank habe eine
gute Woche ja du und wir hören uns in
genau sieben Tagen ja aber bis dann
tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]